All right,
I from I've put two quotations on the board for your consideration.
The first is from Norman mailer.
This is from advertisements for myself.
Um,
he says,
Jack Kerouac lacked discipline,
intelligence,
honesty and a sense of the novel.
Of course some people might apply those adjectives to male or himself,
but um,
that's what mailer said on the road.
This is from a critic named George [inaudible].
This is from a 1974 article about on the road is a love story,
not a travel log and certainly not a call to revolution.
So,
uh,
I put these up here to sort of sit in the background of what I'm going to talk
to you about today,
about the ultimate payoff for Kerouac's effort and the beats effort more
generally to imagine a language that is the adequate analog to experience a
language that is itself a kind of experience and further that is an ecstatic,
mystical kind of experience.
Last time.
In addition to introducing that idea of language to you,
I conducted a reading of the first part of the novel where I suggested that
Kerouac tells us a story that is not so much about the escape from an American
consumer culture of the postwar period.
Um,
as it is a story about the absolute immersion in a culture of consumption.
So what sal paradise consumes on the road,
uh,
extends from Pi as I demonstrated to you by the multiple references,
um,
the simple food that the body needs and wants to girls.
All the women that he tries to sleep within that Dean tries to sleep with,
um,
over the course of the novel to money and the consumer goods that come with it
in order to build a middle class American life with his aunt in New York.
Remember,
he buys the icebox,
the first electric icebox of their family,
the first refrigerator of their family when he comes back from his first road
trip to a kind of mystical access to America,
a history of Jazz.
There's a whole set of mystical,
um,
cultural artifacts that sal paradise and his friends consume over the course of
this novel.
So I want to begin just by pointing to you,
uh,
on page 297
okay.
Uh,
someone more complex example of what this looks like towards the end of the
novel.
Yeah.
This is at the bottom of that page.
They're driving out of Mexico,
so,
and dean
and they meet um,
indigenous people along the road as we climbed the air group cooler and the
Indian girls on the road warrior shawls over their heads and shoulders.
They hailed us desperately.
We stopped to see they wanted to sell us little pieces of rock crystal.
They're great brown,
innocent eyes looked into ours with such soulful intensity that not one of us
had the slightest sexual thought about them.
Moreover,
they were very young.
Some of them 11 and looking almost 30.
Look at those eyes.
Breathe Dean.
They were like the eyes of the virgin mother when she was a child.
We saw in them the tender and forgiving gaze of Jesus and they stared on
flinching into ours.
We rubbed our nervous blue eyes and looked again.
Still,
they penetrated us with sorrowful and him nautic gleam.
When they talked,
they suddenly became frantic and almost silly in their silence.
They were themselves.
They've only recently learned to sell these crystals since the highway was built
about 10 years back.
Up until that time,
this entire nation must have been silent.
That's dean
in this fantasy about the indigenous girls.
What you see is a commitment to language and the activity of selling,
buying and selling entirely entwined with one another.
So the fantasy here is that it's selling and buying that produces in them a
language that looks very much like the language that's frequently attributed to
dean.
Frantic and silly,
almost silly.
You remember as the,
as the novel goes on and dean gets more and more hyper sort of wigged out,
his language becomes more and more frantic and more and more actually silly.
So this is here,
attributed to them.
There are other fantasies at work here,
obviously.
Um,
one is that they are reading a kind of Christian essential ism into these
people,
into their eyes.
They see the Virgin Mary and they see Jesus,
um,
there's a whole mystical objectification of these people that's going on that's
lie to the religious strains of this novel,
which I'm going to pick up again,
um,
a little bit later on in my lecture today.
Yeah.
So this is a more complex and sort of dance example of how that consumer,
that push to consume that consumer sense drives and motivates the novel and
plays out in what they see when they're on the road.
Okay.
In that passage that I read to you,
um,
when they're in the mountains in Colorado drunk yelling,
they call themselves mad drunk.
Can Americans,
well,
what does America mean in this novel and what does it mean to be an American in
this novel?
So that's the question I'd like to take up today.
First
coming from Lolita,
the vision of America and on the road looks quite different in Lolita.
The vision of America is my new toy.
It's detailed.
It's concrete.
Okay.
Remember,
for example,
the comfy cabins that novakof gives us as Lolita and Humbert tour around the,
the painful Luminis tiny detail of all that they see on the road.
Think to yourself.
Do you see any of that kind of detail in this book?
I see shaking heads.
No,
we really don't.
What do we see instead?
What America do we see,
um,
I'm going to look back to a passage I talked about in a different vein last time
on 26 and 27 just for one quick example.
This is,
remember when he's hitched a ride in this truck and it's a truck bed full of uh,
men who have hitched rides and he's talking with Mississippi gene.
This is at the bottom of 26.
There was something so indivisibly reminiscent of big slim hazard in Mrs. Slip
sippy genes,
demeanor that I said,
do you happen to have met a fellow called big slim hazard somewhere?
And he said,
you mean that tall fellow with the big laugh?
Well that sounds like him.
He came from Ruston Louisiana.
That's right.
Louisiana slim.
He's sometimes called.
Yes sir.
I sure have met big slim and he used to work in the east Texas oil fields.
East Texas is right and now he's punching cows.
And that was exactly right and still I couldn't believe Jean could really have
known slim,
whom I'd been looking for more or less for years.
Yeah.
In this scene,
big slim hazard is an type just as Mississippi gene is himself.
Their names tell you that they're almost cartoonishly,
uh,
American types.
The fact that Mississippi gene knows this vague person,
big slim hazard gives you the feeling that America is a tiny community in which
these types loom large,
that anyone from anywhere,
if he's the right kind of American,
will know the other members of that American tribe of types.
So Mississippi gene knows the America that sound knows,
and it's America populated by these larger than life figures.
The very vagueness of the description,
you mean the tall fellow with the big laugh?
How many people can we imagine who might fit that description?
It's like telling your horoscope,
if you're general enough,
you're going to make a match.
So Sao is convinced,
he wants to be convinced.
He desperately wants to be convinced that Mississippi gene knows big,
slim hazard.
Let's look at another example
on page 59
this is something else sal wants.
I wanted to see Denver 10 years ago when they were all children.
That's Chad and dean and the other Denver natives they have among them in their
gang and in the sunny cherry blossom morning of springtime in the Rockies,
rolling their hoops up.
The joyous alleys full of promise,
the whole game and dean ragged and dirty prowling by himself in his preoccupied
frenzy.
There's a nostalgia here,
not for the past of the old west.
It's important that Denver's in the West.
It's the nostalgia here is not for the the old west,
but for the young west.
The West in on the road is an area of youth.
It's always in American lore,
been an area of adventure and imagination.
Yeah,
but this is well after the end of manifest destiny.
There is no border in the west.
So sal has to reinvent one and in some sense it's a border of time.
It's a spring of youth that's inaccessible somehow to sell that these men he's
with,
who are so exciting to him as their own kind of western American type that they
blossomed and grew in this particular place and he wants to have been there with
them.
So in a way,
by longing to be where they were when they were children,
by longing to inhabit that time as well.
He wants to become them.
So this is just one of the ways that sal longs to assimilate them to himself.
The other big way of course is through Dean's language,
but this is another way.
It's a vision of the West as a place of a generally male.
You
okay?
When he's back in New York,
this is on page one 25
his New York friends meet his road friends and are delighted by them.
This is one of his friends.
So where did you find these absolutely wonderful people.
I've never seen anyone like them.
I found them in the west.
So there's that sense of the West as a source and what he's going to do is take
them back east.
So the West is a fountain of youthful energy that sal continually draws back to
the east,
to New York.
Sal's never really going to be gone from New York that long.
He never really wants to leave and one sign of it is that icebox,
but the other side of it is that he continually returns and takes these people
with him
and part of the pleasure for him is to do that transaction to enliven the old
east with the young west.
These are all stereotypes of America,
but sal really believes them and really inhabits them.
Now look on one 72
okay.
This is sal in one of his major moments of vision.
He's in New Orleans and he's on market street.
Oh,
sorry.
He's sorry.
He's in San Francisco and he's on market street.
Okay.
This is the middle of one 72
I looked down market street.
I didn't know whether it was that or canal street in New Orleans.
It led to water ambiguous,
universal water just as 40 street.
New York leads to water and you never know where you are.
I thought of Ed Duncan's ghost on Times Square.
I was delirious.
I wanted to go back and layer at my strange Dickensian mother in the hash joint.
I tingled all over from head to foot.
It seemed I had a whole host of memories going back to 1750 in England and then
I was in San Francisco.
Now only in another life and in another body.
No,
that woman's seem to say would that terrified glance don't come back and play
your honest,
hardworking mother.
You are no longer like a son to me and like your father.
My first husband air this kindly Greek took pity on me.
The proprietor was a Greek with hairy arms.
You are no good inclined to drunkenness and routes and final disgraceful robbery
of the fruits of my own belabors in the habitat,
Sri.
Oh son.
Did you not ever go on your knees and pray for deliverance from all your sins
and scoundrels?
Acts lost boy depart.
Do not haunt my soul.
I have done well for getting you reopen.
No old wounds be as if you had never returned and looked into me to see my
laboring.
Humility is my few scrub penny's Hungary to grab quick to deprive,
sullen on loved mean minded son of my flesh son,
son.
It made me want to think of old of the Big pop vision and Grit.
Grit,
no,
with old bowl.
And for just a moment,
I had reached the point of ecstasy that I always wanted to reach,
which was the complete step across chronological time into timeless shadows and
wonderment in the bleakness of the mortal realm and the sensation of death
kicking at my heels to move on with a phantom dogging it's own heals and myself
hurrying to a plank where all the angels dove off and flew into the holy void of
uncreative emptiness.
The potent and inconceivable radiants is shining and bright mind essence,
innumerable lotus lands falling open in the magic mouth swarm of heaven.
That language at the end there is pure Alan Ginsburg.
Yeah,
so that's that incantatory beat mysticism.
It's mysticism of emptiness in the end,
but what fills that emptiness as we lead up to that moment is this fantasy of
trans historical existence that he can somehow embody a whole human story across
time.
Where's that story coming from?
Well,
this is a Dickensian mother.
It's dickens in part,
that
stereotype of old London of the urban working class.
But it's not just dickens.
Moby Dick is here too.
If look at that litany of streets that lead down to the water.
Uh,
any of you who have read Moby Dick will recall that Ishmael talks at the
beginning before he gets on the p Quad,
he talks about how streets that lead to water draw you inevitably.
And he talks about all the streets in New York that ended in water and he has
this long meditation on that aspect of city geography.
Well here's Sao having that meditation too.
So what you see in this passage is not only a sort of mystical trans historical
fantasy,
but a literary one.
He's getting his mythology not just from the cupboard of stereotypes that are
proper to American self conception.
He's looking back to literary stories too that he can assimilate into his
experience and read through experience through.
So that every little thing he experiences like this moment of abandonment,
Dean has gone off with Camille.
Mary Lou is off somewhere else.
He starved.
He doesn't have any place to go,
but it becomes a moment of vision and it can be a moment of vision because he
has these ways of layering over that experience with mythic and literary
significance.
Okay.
Finally on one 47 we have another example of this and it shows us,
uh,
something even a little different
or it pushes the point further.
This is in New Orleans.
Okay.
There was a mythic Raith the fog,
this is in the middle of that big paragraph
over the Brown waters that night together with dark driftwoods and across the
way New Orleans glowed orange bright with a few dark ships at her,
him ghostly fog bound Serino ships with Spanish balconies and ornamental poops
till you got up close and saw they were just old freighters from Sweden and
Panama.
The ferry fires glowed in the night.
The same negroes plied the shovel in saying old big slim hazard had once worked
on the Algiers ferry as a deck hand.
This made me think of Mississippi gene too.
And as the river pour down from mid America by starlight.
I knew,
I knew like mad that everything I had ever known and would ever know was one
strange to say too,
that night we crossed the ferry with bully a girl committed suicide off the deck
either just before or just after us.
We saw it in the paper next day.
Okay,
here you get a dream,
not just of trans historical time,
the Spanish ships that turn out just to be freighters from Sweden and Panama.
You get another nod to Melville Serino ships.
Benito.
Serena is one of,
um,
Melville Melville's famous novels.
Um,
we were all that everything I would ever know was one.
Yeah.
The oneness that he's looking for is partly that oneness of mystical emptiness
that we saw in the last passage.
But here we get the sense of the racial oneness that comes out in some of the
other parts of the novel,
the,
uh,
the negroes plying the shovel and singing another American type.
But this is a type with which sell longs to merge.
And this is how on 71 79 and one 80 this is how he imagines a way out of
himself.
So this is on one 79 so I'm moving from the question of what does America look
like?
What's the mythic vocabulary that sal is using to,
how does he find his identity as an as an American?
So first he makes America mythic rather than specific.
If we compare him back to Novaka off,
and then he enters into that mythology through acts of identification.
And here's one of the most important.
At dusk,
I walked,
I felt like a speck on the surface of the sad red earth.
I pass the Windsor Hotel where Dean Moriarty had lived with his father in the
depression thirties as of your,
I looked everywhere for the sat and Fabled Tin Smith of my mind.
Either you find someone who looks like your father in places like Fontana or you
look for a friend's father where he is no more.
At Lilac evening,
I walked with every muscle aching along the lights of 27th and Welton in the
Denver colored section wishing I were a negro.
Feeling that the best the white world had offered was not enough ecstasy for me.
Not enough life.
Joy Kicks,
darkness,
music.
Not Enough night.
He goes on in this vein for that whole paragraph.
Or if you just skimmed down,
uh,
I was only myself,
Sal Paradise,
sad,
strolling in this violet dark,
this unbearably sweet night,
wishing I could exchange worlds with the happy,
true hearted,
Ecstatic Negros of America.
Well,
this is hugely stereotypically the stereotypical hugely appropriative Sao wants
to take the entire life experience of a group of people and suck it into
himself.
Now you want to ask yourself,
what is the sadness that motivates this appropriation?
Why does he want to become the Negro?
He says in another moment,
I was Mexican.
He's always trying to be more exotic than himself
than simple sal paradise.
Well,
Baldwin had something to say about this.
James Baldwin,
um,
characterize this passage as a absolute nonsense and offensive nonsense at that.
And yet there is real pain in it and real loss,
however thin.
And it is thin,
thin because it,
uh,
it,
site.
Uh,
let's see.
Sorry,
there's a Typo in my note here.
Some,
uh,
it,
resides a,
does not refer to reality,
but to a dream.
That's what it is.
It does not refer to reality,
but to a dream.
And he says of his own writing,
I had tried to convey something of what it felt like to be a negro and no one
had been able to listen.
They wanted their romance.
Well,
I think that's a pretty clear,
clear eyed view and a clear indictment of what Carol is doing through the
character of sal.
Sal in this moment becomes so naive,
naive of history of actual lived history of his own country.
But as you've seen,
the mythic quality of America has pushed all of that aside.
So there's not just the comfy cabins that we don't see.
It's the whole history of slavery.
And he goes,
when he goes picking in the cotton fields,
he imagines that he could be a slave.
And then he makes some comments about how well he could never pick cotton fast
enough.
He's just not able to do it as,
as black men are.
So it ma,
it's motivated by a huge blindness about the racial history of the United States
in any of its detail.
That sense of the oneness,
I think points to why and how he makes that illusion,
the oneness.
He felt that it was all one.
The oneness is elevated from this sense of appropriation to a mystical level.
So that oneness looks something like the Buddhism that Kerouac studied for a
time.
It looks like something than the effort for sal just to be something exotic.
It looks like by entering into that oneness,
by adopting all these different identities that sal participates into some
larger mystical body,
but what is that logical,
larger mystical body?
We've been given one candidate that it's America,
that it's somehow America.
And I want you to keep this in mind and make a note to yourself.
Think about this vision of an American mystical oneness.
When you go to read cry of lot 49 cause you're going to see something quite
similar there.
There's actually a wonderful episode and on the road that is nearly a carbon
copy of what you'll see later in crying of lot 49 where Dean looks down on Salt
Lake City at night and he looks at the pattern of the lights down below him at a
pub,
Moss in crying of lot 49,
we'll sit up,
uh,
on on a bluff overlooking San Narcisso and she'll look down at the pattern of
lights and she'll,
it's,
it's an important moment in that novel moment of,
of religious revelation.
But what's being revealed remains in pension,
quite difficult to pin down here.
It's,
it's equally vague.
So on five,
back to that question,
what can motivate this kind of effort?
On page one 81 he says,
yeah,
there was excitement in the air,
was filled with the vibration of really joyous life that knows nothing of
disappointment and white sorrows and all that.
The Old Negro man had a can of beer in his coat pocket,
which he proceeded to open in the old white man enviously I'd the can and groped
in his pocket to see if he could buy a Cantu.
How I died.
I walked away from there.
And then this wonderful transition,
I went to see a rich girl.
I knew in the morning,
she pulled a hundred dollar bill out of her silk stocking and said,
you've been talking of a trip to Frisco.
That being the case,
take this and go have your fun.
So all my problems were solved.
Um,
Sao needs the rich girl
to keep his vision fueled,
but the white sorrows are part of what it pays for.
Okay.
The rich girl provides him with in a way with these white sorrows,
she funds them.
You can have white sorrows,
whatever those really are.
You can have white sorrows.
If you have the hundred dollar bill to send you off on one of these odysseys,
you're not pinned down to a place working for a living.
Yep.
I'm not going to talk about,
um,
about jazz and the way it figures,
but I hope that you will have a chance to talk about that in section because
that brings together,
um,
several elements of what's important in the novel.
Um,
I want to focus now on the sadness.
I don't know if you noticed how often that adjective appears in the novel.
Did any of you notice that?
Sadness,
sadness,
sad night.
One of the saddest things after Dean and sal get into their own leave fight
really is the uneaten food on Dean's plate.
The sadness of the uneaten food.
What sad in this novel I think is the way the specificity of persons push back
against that general collapse into mystical communing with one another.
What sad.
Dean's wife,
Camille and their baby,
it's sad.
He abandons them and she's left with them.
All the women in Dean's life call him to the carpet and tell him of all his
sins.
That's a sad moment in the novel.
A moment of difficulty.
A moment of specificity.
Also,
what else is sad?
It's sad when Dean leave Sao feverish in Mexico,
he's off.
He has his girls to chase his wife to go back to,
to divorce,
whichever one is which.
He has all these machinations to attend to.
The friendship between the two in the end doesn't seem to mean very much,
or at least in that moment,
it doesn't seem to mean very much
if
George [inaudible] is right,
that this is a love story.
It's the love story between sal and dean.
And I hope as you were reading,
you notice that chapter opening where once again,
dean appears at the door when sal shows up and he's totally naked.
Hope you noticed that it's the third time that we see that.
So there's an eroticism between them and there is this heartbreaking love that
sal has for dean.
And if you track that through the major turning points in the second two thirds
of the novel are moments when sal makes it clear to dean that he actually cares
about him.
And I can point you to some of these pages.
Um,
this is on one 89.
I'm not going to do them all because there's something else I want to show you
today.
Okay?
This is,
um,
after,
after Dean has been sort of called to the carpet.
Uh,
and he says,
um,
the song,
the thumb,
this is on one 88,
the thumb became the symbol of Dean's final development.
He no longer cared about anything as before,
but now he also cared about everything in principle.
That's such a great encapsulation of not caring about any specific thing,
but still being incredibly invested.
But this is mirrored by sounds very specific investment in Dean.
And this is on the bottom of the facing page on one 89
resolutely and firmly,
I repeated what I said,
come to New York with me.
I've got the money.
I looked at him,
my eyes were watering with embarrassment and tears still.
He stared at me.
Now his eyes were blank.
And looking through me,
it was probably the pivotal point of our friendship when he realized I had
actually spent some hours thinking about him and his troubles and he was trying
to place that in his tremendously involved and tormented mental categories.
So he finally realizes that Sao actually has a specific love for him not caring
about him somehow.
In principle,
which is the way of course that,
that um,
dean cares.
So this is the sadness of the novel.
It's this unrequited love dean is never capable of loving sow in the same way
that sal loves dean.
And at the very end when sal has to leave Dean on the street,
I actually I love how this works.
He's in the back of a Cadillac.
Okay.
His friend Remy is taking him in the limousine to a concert,
a Duke Ellington concert,
which is important by the way.
Um,
and I'll leave you to think about why that might be important.
Remy won't have dean in the car.
So the car drives on sow is with a new girlfriend,
Laura,
about whom to whom he's told all about dean,
Dean ragged and a moth eaten coat overcoat he bought specially for the freezing
temperatures of the east,
walked off alone in the last I saw of him,
he rounded the corner of seventh avenue eyes on the street ahead and bent to it
again.
Pour a little Laura,
my baby to whom I told everything about dean began almost to cry.
Oh,
we shouldn't let him go like this.
What will,
what will we do?
Old Deans gone.
I thought out loud.
I said,
he'll be all right and off he went to the sad and distinct and off we went to
the sad and disinclined concert for which I had no stomach,
whatever.
And all the time I was thinking of Dean and how he got back on the train and
rode over 3000 miles over that awful land and never knew why he had come any way
except to see me
in that moment.
South supplies the answer for why Dean came,
never knew why he had come anyway.
And then south supplies except to see me and his own pain and tears are routed
through Laura.
It's Laura who cries at deans abandonment while he maintains this,
uh,
this composure,
this masculine composure,
he'll be all right.
But the sadness here is surely Sal's
okay.
By the end,
the language of experience.
This is on three Oh four.
The language of experience that dean represents is completely exhausted.
This is how dean talks at the very end.
Okay?
He couldn't talk anymore.
He hopped and laughed.
He stuttered and flooded his hands and said,
ah,
you must listen to hear.
We listened all ears.
But he forgot what he wanted to say.
Really.
Listen,
look,
dear south,
suite lower,
I've come,
I've gone.
But wait.
Ah,
yes.
And he stared with rocky sorrow into his hands.
Can't talk no more.
Do you understand that it is or might be.
But listen,
we all listened.
He was listening to sounds in the night.
Yes,
he whispered with all,
but you see no need to talk anymore.
And further
Dean's language has gone from this sort of quasi academic jibberish of the
beginning of the novel to this completely fragmented,
broken version of the yeses and Aahs and wows of those early ecstatic days.
So Sal's language by the end has absorbed some of this and yet gone on to honor
a kind of coherence that dean cannot inhabit anymore.
Or maybe the d never inhabited.
Okay.
So the last sentence of the book,
um,
which I want to read to you.
I think I have time just because it's,
this is the language that sal comes out of it with or that Kerouac comes out
with as the payoff for opening language in the ways that Dean's language of
immediacy represents.
So this is one sentence,
page three Oh seven the last paragraph.
So in America when the sun goes down and I sit on the old broken down river pier
watching the long,
long skies over New Jersey,
and since all that raw land that rolls in,
one unbelievable huge bulge over the west coast and all that road going,
all the people dreaming in the immensity of it.
And in Iowa,
I know by now the children must be crying in the land where they let the
children cry.
And tonight the stars will be out and don't you know that God is Poo bear.
The evening star must be drooping and shedding her sparkler dims on the prairie,
which is just before the coming of complete night that blesses the earth,
darkens all rivers,
cups the peaks and folds the final shore in.
And nobody,
nobody knows what is going to happen to anybody besides the four Lauren rags of
growing old.
I think of Dean Moriarty.
I even think of old Dean Moriarty,
the father we never found,
I think of Dean Moriarty.
So he's co he's blasted open the syntax of that sentence piled clause upon
clause upon clause phrase on phrase
to include that whole road in the one sentence.
So if the dream of cure wax language is to pour experience into language and
make language immediate,
this sentence is a very fine example of the payoff.
There's a kind of goofiness at the center of it.
God is Poo bear.
What does that mean?
God is just a toy.
God is a children's story.
But then there's that lyrical elegiac always sad sense of longing and the excess
of the end.
Dean Moriarty,
Dean Moriarty's,
father,
Dean Moriarty.
You can't just say it once.
You have to try to fill that void by saying it two times and by invoking his
father a third time.
So the excess and the longing are,
they're each trying to drive or satisfy the other.
Now if we had any doubts that on the road is mythic in itself.
I just want to show you quickly two things.
In 2007 on the road had its 50th anniversary of publication.
It was written in 1951 and it was published in 1957 by Viking.
So,
uh,
last year we were treated to these two,
these two books.
One thing that fascinates me about them is that they are examples of how
publishing houses rely on known names for making money.
So Viking owns,
uh,
the,
it has has on the road in their back list so they can make new copies of this.
The pagination of this is exactly the same.
All they did was bind.
They,
they made a retro cover and they bound the original book review from the New
York Times into the front.
They just printed that in and then they just reproduce the text again.
So it becomes a sort of keepsake book.
Um,
I'm not sure that a lot of people are going to read this book,
but a lot of people might buy it as a keepsake.
This is the original scroll version.
This is like the Sop to scholars.
This is for the scholarly buyer is for people like me or not like me.
Um,
this is the,
the original typescript put into pages.
But as I think I mentioned in my first lecture,
Kerouac wrote the manuscript for on the road on one long hundred and 20 foot
roll of paper.
He's stuck in the typewriter,
no paragraphs,
no nothing.
He just went.
So this book reproduces that just breaking it as the pages demand instead of
actually giving us a scroll,
which would be pretty cool.
But what else they do is they lard it with scholarly articles.
There are,
let's see,
uh,
three scholarly articles and then there's a note on the editing of the text and
there's suggestions for further reading.
It makes it into a real literary object,
sort of like a modernist texts.
And what I love here is that apparently the very,
very beginning of the scroll,
um,
cure plaque made a typo
and the editor says,
I read it,
I let the Typo stand here.
Does the editor Howard canal,
because it's so beautifully suggest the sound of a car misfiring before starting
up for a long journey.
I have left uncorrected the manuscripts opening line,
which is
I met,
met Neal not long before my father died.
There's the fantasy that the writing approximates the actual car trip met met.
Oh,
it sounds like a car starting.
I'm going to leave that in there.
So the editors just by completely by
the techs own mythology and produce all this apparatus around it to help us,
uh,
help us believe it too.
Now the last thing I want to show you is on a less skeptical note.
Okay.
If you ever doubt
that the legend and the dream of on the road is alive and is powerful in art,
literary art and visual art today,
all you need to do is look at um,
okay.
A very recent,
yeah.
Work of digital art.
Yeah.
This is young.
Hey Chang,
heavy industries,
which is a collaboration of an American man and a Korean woman who create online
digital artworks and this is one of them from 2002 called Dakota.
And I think you will see immediately,
um,
how and why it is related to on the road.
It's also related to Ezra pound's Cantos but I'm not going to burden you with
that right now.
What I want you to do is just think about this.
It runs about six minutes.
Um,
so I'm going to let that go now.
All right?
Okay.
So if you ever doubted that the dream of,
of an immediate language that is somehow the correlate to jazz and experience,
that's,
that's your dream living on.
Okay.